La volta al món a peu, dia 311.
Bé, s'ha aixecat el dia com era d'esperar, és a dir, sense pluja,
però bastant ennubolat,
i com us he dit, anem a fer una excursió especial,
en un lloc sorprenent.
Bé, jo vaig amb la motxilla, però realment podria no anar,
perquè són 5 quilòmetres d'anar, 5 de tornar.
Així m'emporto l'aigua i, per si de cas,
el material impermeable no vagi a ser que plogui.
Bé, jo vaig amb la motxilla i, per si de cas,
Neveres improvisades. Aquí tenim, segons m'han dit,
iogurt i llet.
I, bé, com l'aigua baixa molt freda perquè baixa de la glacera,
que ja ho sàpiga, doncs, clar, es manté fred.
Aquí, quan demanes aigua, et donen l'aigua de la seta,
que és l'aigua d'aquí, és aquesta aigua mateixa.
L'estic bevent sense filtrar, espero que no hi hagi cap problema,
i surt molt tèrbola.
Surt molt tèrbola,
suposo que perquè arrossega sorreta
i tal, la gent d'aquí l'ha begut tota la vida.
Jo també ho estic fent perquè, si filtres això,
el filtre quedaria completament obstruït en 0,1.
També diuen que l'aigua de glacera no és del tot bona
perquè no porta minerals.
Llavors, clar, no t'hidrata bé, perquè tal,
llavors, quan camines, si pots i tal,
jo que, si agafes aigua de glacera,
l'hauries de suplementar amb electrolits,
cosa que, doncs, evidentment no estic fent.
Estic aquí amb el ministre de L'Acenciació de la
Universitat Autòntoma de Catalunya.
Estic aquí amb el ministre de la Creativitat Alta.
Estic aquí amb el Lt. De Mèdica Eliao les òrgans investidors
del Departament d'Eurocogn hosek i
de Polèmia i demés.
La situació publicada aquesta estinguda és atenção!
Estic aquí amb la ministra de foca d'E tranquònica,
de la ciutat de Barcelona, el senyor Manuela Rodríguez.
Fins demà!
Doncs ja hem arribat!
Què és això?
Què és aquesta espanada?
El Camil ens ha portat fins aquí.
Això és un estadi de críquet.
Sí, aquí, al costat d'aquesta paret gegant,
aquesta glacera que tenim aquí al davant,
les ovelles...
Sí, sí, un estadi natural de críquet.
No sé res del críquet,
però, bueno, aquesta és una com central de formigó.
Aquí és on tiren la pilota.
I rematen.
Bueno, m'han dit que pugen aquí els caps de setmana a jugar,
però al Camil no, al Camil li agrada més el vòlei-vol.
Increïble, eh, el joc?
M'encanta que hi hagi ovelles pasturant a l'estadi.
Bueno, és supermaco, això, eh?
Sí, sí, ara ja es veu la glacera aquí,
però ara en veurem una altra.
Hem pujat una mica més.
Aquí tenim la pista de críquet.
Allà tenim la glacera blava o blanca,
maca, però no s'acaba la glacera allà,
sinó que segueix.
I tot això també és glacera.
Black glacier, em diuen que es diu.
Glacera negra.
Totes aquestes pedres,
tot això sota, hi ha gel.
De fet, es veu una mica, no?,
que sí que hi ha punts que són blancs.
Llavors, clar, perquè sí que es pot travessar,
entre cometes, tranquil·lament, no?
Bueno, amb molt de compte,
perquè hi ha...
Segueixen haver-hi esquerdes,
crevasses, que es diu, en francès.
Però bueno, va, mola moltíssim, això, eh?
Ja anem baixant.
Hem trigat dues hores a pujar.
I 5 km, 570 metres de desneig positiu.
Ja dic que aquesta part d'aquí,
fins a la pujada aquesta on es veia la glacera,
era bastant empinada.
I les sabates, sí, les sabates aquestes,
que recordeu que no tenen sola de trail,
no ens deu ni do, eh?
No, o sigui, no m'he arriscat cap vegada.
S'han comportat superbé.
Jo crec que val més l'esquíl,
l'habilitat com a senderista,
que l'equipament que portis.
Hora de dinar.
Hem vingut a la guesthouse de l'habit.
What are we eating now, today?
This is our traditional dish, curry julie.
Curry julie?
Curry julie, yeah.
This is our cultural dish
and we make local butter,
a pure organic dish, yeah.
Butter with beef, right?
Butter with beef.
Pure.
With chapati?
Yeah, with chapati.
Kamali.
And it's typical from this region,
but that is called Nagar Bali?
Yeah, Nagar Bali.
This is Nagar Bali.
Camil told me that this dish,
it takes a long time to prepare.
Three hours, maybe?
Four hours?
Yeah, three to four hours minimum.
Okay, looks very good. Thank you very much.
Yeah, you taste first and...
Yes, sure, sure.
Les sis de la tarda,
fa molta estona que hem tornat,
hem estat fent una bona migdiada,
ja que tinc un dia així de bastant descans a aprofitar.
I ni resta de la pluja, tu.
Estic bastant indignat.
De fet, cap allà, veig el cel blau i tot.
Podríem haver fet avui l'excursió fins al camp base?
Jo crec que sí.
Potser a l'Averit Núvols no hauríem vist tant la cosa maca,
però jo crec que la hauríem pogut fer, però bueno, tu.
La farem demà, Inxal·lar.
Bueno, us poso el track, encara que no el veureu a l'estrava,
això és el que hem fet avui, més o menys.
Han sigut, no sé si uns vuit, deu quilòmetres.
També és tan maco, el camp de críquet aquest.
I, bueno, aprofitar que aquest vídeo és així una mica més curtet
per dir-vos que molts de vosaltres, quan vaig a determinats països,
jo què sé, Turquia, el que sigui, em dieu,
oh, mira, jo vaig anar a Atalant i vaig anar per aquí,
més aixà, més allà, em recomaneu coses, no?
Doncs aquí a Pakistan, i també a la zona de la Xina,
hi ha diverses persones que em van enviar imatges
dels seus viatges de fa 20 o 30 anys.
Venir aquí, o sigui, jo sempre dic que la volta amb una peu
és la mare de totes les aventures, no?
Però viatjar fa 20 o 30 anys, o més,
hi ha algú que m'ha enviat fotos de l'any 88,
això sí que és una aventura, sense internet, sense res.
Enveja sana, i bueno, mireu, per exemple,
l'Àngels m'envia fotos de la carretera del Caracol,
aquí a Pakistan, molt diferent de com és ara,
i molt més perillós, però existia, existia la carretera,
més petita, més estreta, amb moltes meses llavissades, suposo.
Una locura, eh? Una locura.
Molt guai.
I després el Carles, que va ser ja, ostres,
no me'n recordo quin any m'ha dit, crec que això,
fa 30 i pico anys, va ser a Hunjerat Pass,
és a dir, la frontera entre la Xina i Pakistan,
i mireu quina diferència.
Us poso per començar la imatge que vaig fer jo.
La foto del meu vídeo,
veureu aquesta espècie de tòtem així, aquesta fita de color blanc,
que té les tanques, les tanques,
aquí era impossible passar, o sigui,
després de les tanques hi havia també una,
una fulla d'aquestes amb ganivetes perquè, bueno,
impossible passar, i aquesta és la imatge de fa, doncs això, mil anys.
En Carles, en Guillem i en Carles, m'ha dit que el citi,
van fer el viatge aquest, i com veieu, no hi havia res,
o sigui, no hi havia cap tanca, m'ha dit,
simplement hi havia la fita aquesta, que està igual, suposo,
al mateix lloc, aquestes coses han de ser inamovibles i sagrades,
i van poder pujar allà tranquil·lament i fer-se la foto.
Guapíssim, guapíssim.
Bé, demà sí, demà farem el trekking del Rakaposhi,
i avui el resum seria que m'he gastat, de moment, 0 euros,
perquè m'estan acumulant tot el que m'he gastat,
i ja m'ho cobraran demà, aquí és on estic,
Diran Inn, bon lloc, bon lloc per estar,
us recomano, també si sou xinesos, i aquí teniu també,
ui, mireu això que ve ara, aquí teniu l'Instagram,
mireu els nois aquests.
Eeeeh!
Un refresc, he parlat amb tres persones, i un té.
Molt bé, senyors, fins demà, bona nit.